if you're
a guest star you should be living like a
co-star if you're recurring you should
be living like a guest star if you're a
series regular you should be living like
a recurring
can you talk about living below your
means and how you've adopted that
early in your career so you don't want
to maybe spend too much here or there
get too confident like this amount's
always going to be coming in
i
have never really in my life
needed like expensive stuff
and i've always been able to live below
my means and really good at balancing my
budget in my checkbook and
even when i
i mean when i was working at accenture i
was making a ton of money and so i did
not spend that money so i did not live
how my coworkers lived and my co-workers
were buying
bmws and living in these like really
fancy apartments in manhattan beach and
i but i i
was always aware of my plan
and i was like oh i got to save this
money because who knows like when i do
get laid off or when i do
um
when accenture finds me out
and realizes that i'm a terrible
employee then i'm gonna need this money
to live on so just from there starting
there i knew that i needed to save and i
knew that i needed to live below my
means because after that i was you know
doing short films for
uh usc and ucla that you don't get paid
for and i was doing a lot of free acting
work just to get the tape
and and i was i was living off you know
my center money for a while and then and
then i would do the waitressing jobs and
the restaurant jobs and
and
that would pay the bills and like i said
i would book a
co-star here and there or a commercial
and and that would be a nice chunk of
money which i knew again that i couldn't
spend right away um
and so i i've always been pretty good
about living below my means something
that one of my friends yvette nicole
brown told me that i always have in the
back of my head
is
if you're
a guest star you should be living like a
co-star if you're recurring you should
be living like a guest star if you're a
series regular you should be living like
a recurring and so i keep i keep that in
the back of my mind and i think about
that a lot and i tell her all the time
i'm like i'm always thinking about that
and she
she's she gives good advice
so when you got let's say the first big
acting related check
did you have a temptation to i want to
splurge this on a b and c
and and did you reward yourself or did
you say no
this is my this is my winter money i
need this
i said this is my winter money i need
this i don't think i've i've never
splurged on anything unless i needed it
so my splurges have always been
if i have a 10 year old laptop then i
need to get a laptop because it keeps
shutting down
or if i have
a six-year-old phone then i'm gonna get
the new iphone um but i'm not someone
who
you know the iphone 13 just came out i
don't need to go rush out and get that
um i think
i'm very happy with small rewards when i
when i book let's say you know
like booking a commercial i'm like okay
i'm gonna go
get pizza for my favorite place or i'm
gonna go get ice cream like like food is
something that i care about a lot and
the foods that i like aren't very
expensive
so so that's a splurge for me i
i'm not someone
i will only go out and buy a car if my
car is on its last legs
and undrivable
so i guess i'm like really good with
money in that sense and i had
there's i love to travel
um
but i
have traveled a lot throughout my
childhood and even up through college so
even when i moved to la i was like oh i
don't need to go to europe because i've
already been to europe or i don't need
to go um spend my money in asia because
i've been to asia so
so i i would always keep that in mind
and i'd be like well i i actually need
to get new headshots as opposed to
do something splurgy and crazy
so so that something that you can
reinvest back into whether it's your
acting career or a film
is something you'll put money into but
it sounds always always
will be i'll be putting money back into
my career right but not you don't need a
new
model of whatever car
no no and i love i love groupon i love
living social i'm always looking for a
deal
where are some of the best places that
an actor or creative can invest in
themselves what can they do i believe
the best thing that you can invest in is
your work so
for example i did a
short film
in
2016 called cowboy and indian
and
this is how it came about basically i
was doing my taxes and i noticed that
there were these stocks that i had never
noticed before and i called
the number
that was that was on the
tax information sheet and i asked oh
what are these stocks and they said oh
these were gifted to you when you left
accenture
and i said excuse me
okay how much are they worth and they
said fifty five hundred dollars and i
said
send me the check
and they say well we don't recommend you
cashing out and i was like send me the
check
and i got a check for fifty five hundred
dollars
that i put directly into
funding my short film cowboy and indian
which i wrote produced directed and
starring
and it was a really freeing experience
because
i gave myself the permission to fail on
making that short because i knew it was
my first short film it would probably
turn out to be a piece of
but guess what nobody was going to be
blamed except for me because i was
putting my own money into it that i
didn't even know i had so it wasn't
money that i needed to make back i was
just like this was free money out there
that was mine
and i had just discovered it
so i had already written the short film
and it was a five page script and i put
my crew together put my cast together
and we went out to the desert to joshua
tree to shoot it it was a one day one
night shoot
and
came back went into post-production
when i when it was finished i said oh
this isn't bad
i was like this is not a bad first short
film
and i started submitting it to film
festivals and
got didn't get into any of the biggies
you know didn't get into sundance tiff
tribeca or south by but i got into
a lot of asian american film festivals
and
indian american film festivals and so i
did the festival circuit i traveled with
it uh i believe it got into over 15 film
festivals in 2017 2018 and it was just
really fun and it was amazing watching
it on the big screen along with four or
five other short films that were in the
same block as mine and i have never
regretted
putting that stock money
into my short film
was that part of like a 401k that they
had it wasn't part of a 401k it was just
it was just stocks it was it was stuff
that you could actually cash out
and get the the price of whatever it was
at that time